we're going to begin this hour after
that brief rain delay an American who
made history by Leading the U.S team to
victory in a grueling around the world
sailing race
wow that's a pretty that is Skipper
Charlie Enright and the 11th Hour racing
they became the first American team to
win the ocean race in a 50-year history
of that race it is a six-month 36
Thousand Mile Journey where the teams
have a dual mission to win yes and to
learn about ocean Health by gathering
data on the world's Waters now if 11th
Hour racing sounds familiar to you it
may be because Ben Tracy introduced us
to them just last month he linked up
with the team in Rhode Island and went
out for a ride
you're about to feel to feel all right
Charlie and Wright is the skipper of
this 60-foot long sailboat but when he
lowers these giant fin-like hydrofoils
into the water so we're gonna hit speeds
of up to 30 miles an hour
he's more like the captain of a rocket
ship
it's not quite like the sailboats I went
out of Camp whoa
whoa indeed Charlie Enright joins us now
on dry land right here on CBS mornings
uh thank you very much for being here uh
how long has it been actually since you
stepped off the boat and do you feel
like a rocking sensation still now I
think we finished on the 29th um so
whatever day it is now yeah you can do
the math yeah you've been going after
this victory for quite a long time how's
it feel to actually get it
it's surreal kind of like being here
with you folks today uh you know it's
been 10 years trying to achieve this
goal and um
it hasn't set in yet yeah I think as
more you know time passes uh day in and
day out it'll kind of sink in a little
more but we shook hands when you come in
you can feel some of the wear and tear
ocean life in the strings the strength
but also you know the calluses yeah
we've got a picture I think that your
team posted of you looking uh pretty
exhausted at the end of this journey
talk to us wow yeah you gotta raise her
since then
pretty well yeah you're looking good uh
talk to us about what makes this race so
grueling
yeah I mean this has been called like
the longest and toughest
um sporting event on the planet and uh I
think it's for good reason you know last
six months it's uh 36 000 miles and uh
we see some pretty crazy stuff you know
we Traverse the treacherous Southern
Ocean you know we got 60 mile an hour
winds 60 foot waves it's like six whoa
but waves yeah which is you know
ironically the length of our boat seats
Charlie makes me think dangerous but yet
when you sit here and we see you hosting
up the the trophy it's a beautiful
trophy by the way I want to know about
the danger and how you guys got through
that and what you're thinking when
you're going through 60-foot waves I
didn't realize the waves were that high
yeah I mean even you know in situations
like that even when they go perfectly
it's a bit treacherous you know so when
things go wrong in situations like that
um you know it can get a little hairy at
times but um you know we we train for
this you know safety is something that
we take very very seriously
um you know I wouldn't say that we get
scared as much as we get like a
heightened sense of awareness and a
respect for the elements oh that's what
we're calling it now yeah heightened
sense of awareness yeah and you're
collecting data too along the way yeah I
mean at this point you know in sport
winning's not enough you know for us the
Project's all about ocean health and you
know we do a lot along the way to
support that initiative you know we have
devices on board that constantly sample
water
um you know and it's measuring for you
know dissolved CO2 salinity sea surface
temperature and then all of that
actually is fed back live from our
satellites to climatologists and
meteorologists and actually some of that
data makes it back to us in the form of
grid files and we use it during our race
so I don't know if you realize this but
in addition to racing and doing science
you can just hang out and do nothing on
a boat you can have a good time if it's
the summer are you planning you could
drink a beer you could have a beer you
know you could kick back you know get
some suntan are you planning to take a
break I mean what do you do now that
you've come back from this yeah you know
honestly um we've just been really
focused on the task at hand I mean this
is all consuming you know as as you'd
imagine and we know that um you know
every version of our future is better if
we capitalize on you know kind of it's
what we had in front of us so I mean I
think some time with the family this
this race takes its toll on a you know a
young family I got white kids I hear
your family actually likes you Charlie
yeah Nate you should know that he was
telling me in the Green Room that you
were on his football fantasy team so oh
yeah the Lions sealed on the water he's
skilled in picking football that's what
I'm talking about yeah all kind of
skills I appreciate I hope I didn't let
you down
um you know you talked about ocean
Health which is important in day and age
that we're living in but I want to talk
about mental health because you have
four other crew members on a 60-foot
long vote so a relatively small boat
middle of the ocean
I mean I I'd have no better way to ask
this than how do you stay sane during
this long journey yeah yeah I think um
you know picking the team's a big part
of that you know you got to pick
individuals that are you know
like-minded you know um you have to have
a little bit of an ego obviously to do
what we do but you have to be able to
put you know the team above yourself
that's a huge thing you got to get
everybody thrown in the direction
focused on the end goal and you know
it's it's hard I mean you guys you have
a little tiff at work and you get to go
home at the end of the day and you know
we are stuck on this boat for up to you
know almost 40 days at a time you know
with our co-workers so you know it can
be difficult you know we have a mental
coach
um you know so we prepare physically um
you know we prepare the boat we prepare
everything but you know we we try to
uh you know Envision everything that
could happen out there exactly could go
wrong or could just occur you know and
um so we spend a lot of time working
with her as uh you know individuals and
as a team and it's the stuff that you
you don't Envision that sneaks up on you
that gets in trouble yeah of course well
huge congratulations and the pictures
are amazing it's a hell of a an
accomplishment thank you appreciate it
yeah well done well done and you look
good I'm glad you're home safe and sound
you and your crew